ah terrible idea so Vinnie and I have
this genius idea to grab all these
different hot sauces put them on wings
and for me to explain the plot to
infinity war which is basically affinity
gauntlet I am kind of terrified about
this kind of thing but if you guys want
to see more stuff like this we're
actually doing spittoon gameplay here
and we'll walk you'll find on elgible
monster make sure you guys go check that
out because our story many guys know who
he is I guess Mel this Jesus dude I am
now cheering for no hot sauce is on
there so Rob what is infinity work I'll
come on I'm going to be careful that
slope so including the move the plot of
Infinity Ward is going to be on dodging
this is the dark side of the pepper yeah
the plot of infinity war is going to be
a combination of sandals quest in the
infinity golem alright so in Pharaoh's
quest they don't have the Infinity
stones before but he ended up finding
out and as you put the Infinity stones
together that they form something called
the Infinity Gauntlet and that if a
person has the Infinity Gauntlet
they're going to be able to use it
quickly there's going to be able to use
it to rigidly control all facets of the
universe through his ideas you know that
was supposed to be a funny skit where
Mark is going to be behind us reacting
the whole time but I think you're legit
dying okay now is that a huge thing for
mr. Seth right while you're sucking in a
princess so that was like okay look if I
get the Infinity Gauntlet I could like
use its power to impress her she'll like
me whatever
so nanos little source capturing the
acidity stones from like all these
different people from like Grand Master
and other cosmic entities so on and so
forth fast-forward to the Infinity core
wait
I want you guys to know I need space is
very dry vases problem is not this is
not a very good idea
and so fast-forward to the Infiniti home
communion infantile to slow down on this
little Pantheon thing
Mephisto who's basically Satan just
hanging out with Thanos battles like our
mistress death I have absolute power do
you love me now
she's like nope so then I was like
halfway don't do well with spicy stuff
man
so that doesn't look okay I know how to
get mr. death to dig so we walked out to
the edge of this little you know
pantheon thing snaps fingers and wipes
now past the life in the universe what
are you doing then shine than me I
double has my life in the interest
you've got three snaps fingers wife some
household life in universe Apple life is
banished there are people who like like
Nick Fury's just like mad what are the
world after they Captain America's like
Marge are they don't go and every vagina
right like while all this is happening
the Silver Surfer crash lands into the
home of dr. strange there we go
I might in putting a lot on the wings no
no a little goes a long way
because you wanted to be internet famous
so gonna knock you put so much all right
go back on camera just a good hot
via the iZombie Hasan has made like the
world's hottest pepper we are now half
away at our hot stream over supper crash
lands with a home with dr. strange and
dr. strange is like you've won the
world's going on the silver surfers like
you Stannis is coming alright so then
that custom saddle swapping on half life
in here alright so two out of the world
well I'm rod is basically like Marvel
Spacey Jesus Lori you got anymore
also you have Gamora you have Pizza
troll David hanging out for a while
doing their own thing living hanging
outside the soldier you have to smell
how hot that is so they come back like
there is elected and so Adam warlock
grabs what's left of a superhero it's
like okay like we need to come up with a
plan but while we're doing that let me
go and talk to like some cosmic entities
and see what's going on if we can't find
a way to keep this from happening dude I
really don't want to do this this is
your idea and over again we're gonna be
plain explain to a delay this like this
yes we are
okay you ready cosmic entity that's
where you left off that's where I left
off dude oh it's the exhale that burns
we're so that warlock I don't know
whatever yeah I'm good you go to the
cosmic entities they go to the Living
Tribunal who's like the judge of the
multiverse get get a good shot get the
next two are the worst yeah and they're
like hey Lurie tribunal or you go do
something could you like step in and you
get yourself involved because nails had
the Infinity Gauntlet oh he's about to
unleash holy hello viewers buddy
tribunal says no battles having the
Infinity Gauntlet is basically
equivalent to the idea that he's taking
over the world of eternity the physical
embodiment universe if eternity cannot
maintain his role oh okay
yeah I'm good man all right so let me
grab you up like FD knows if eternity
can maintain its fall because nails is
too powerful
but eternity deserves to lose so they're
helping infuse all like whatever they're
like whatever we'll do what we have to
do in order to win my house are a little
on fire cured man this was a bad idea if
you guys like this let him know in the
comments down below in this video a like
cuz I'll do this weekly know so Adam rod
runs
your superheroes what's left them races
over to where fantasies
I really don't want to eat this less and
over going in how would you have left
everything at this we're about halfway
through explain a little more then right
because you only have two sauces today
wreath off to work nanos is right and so
they're like so silver slippers or ever
lost or he's like okay tomatoes their
net panels home economist is so much
like Oakland silver surfer stay with me
you stay beside me our superheroes judo
and you trying to beat Thanos what
follows is one of the most spectacular a
students in the history of comics so the
earth superhero would stand no chance
whatsoever like one of them I think it's
nowhere tries to attack that most and
most turns into the blocks electron's
blocks because the affinity to go to let
them work all time and space he grabs
died rats to destroy the Incredible Hulk
I think it frozen like 65 million years
into the past like absolutely have any
backhanded him no no that's that's no he
just backhanded him just as he was
annoyed with Captain America it's like
The Last Man Standing
all right oh my god keep Captain America
hold on Last Man Standing go we go
she was going in Lord Jesus no work Oh
Lord Jesus as well as a kid isn't as
okay
Oh God boy dreams come more Judah's over
please hmm are you back to m5 will you
face the camera Oh Lord you got him
Chuck America how diverse limitless
movies are before Captain America's Last
Man Standing
all the superheroes were fighting you're
the whole reason why the Silver Surfer
stay behind and the last one is Mad Dog
25th anniversary when millions go but my
tongue is on fire oh god I feel like I'm
gonna do so whole reason one two
superheroes are fighting is because they
were supposed to be a distraction
they're just trapped so there's nothing
like probably four or five going to go
easy on me okay I get it all right
so anyway the superheroes are supposed
to be a distraction and Adam warlock was
way to put a perfect layer that Mehcad a
lot of as good as good as it'll be on
you there's a little distraction and
order steal the Infinity Gauntlet
Fontana okay all right so in this moment
of Huber's is over there did you guys
really like it this gets 10,000 I want
to do if you smash the like button model
do this every other day every other day
smash it I wish I had the ability goes
like me does he go so then I'm supposed
to punch a superhero this put somebody
all over who it is
why I go oh oh oh I want to do to my
channel one Adam what are you doing boom
oh oh oh god it's gone this is joy
[Applause]
[Music]
and anyone just over something like oh I
can change so summer so we tried to grab
the offender garland Dennis more diverse
fauna dodging all G here we scream it
takes off and then another piece like
our when you're begging I so all this is
happening
captain Americans in Westminster only I
can see that you'll bleed up of all that
yogurt man so no oh how did you just had
water comes ready so so why leave office
racing off the capita miracle ask me a
favor
that's something you said Captain
America last night that on yeah doesn't
done you may do it two or three high so
high settles back hands captain here as
I hung you back with more heat as your
waited you're like it's clear we go ah
so so test we got us Captain America
shield pieces all right I'm your
daughter here in each actor is left out
okay it's a more calm type of you with
the constant in the air go on just go
sir oil or tails
oh hey wasn't Brock oh man
man so because we get peace I'll get
rest my fan of the Celestials like
throwing because nothing works kind of
eternity the living embodiment of the
universe shows up
so Jesus and like eternity get the
crunch pop Dantas so that looks like the
most comical being in that and the
universe right well one of the things
that was going on is nebula within the
background and that has two main nebula
all like weird-lookin in the South all
over the reason why but she was don't
like the cave
Debu low like they don't make this up
infinity he's just sitting alone chair
with an affinity goblet camera water
like nebula snatches the Infinity
Gauntlet away from Stannis and so nebula
has the affinity golisano's goes back to
being normal or that everybody's like
man this is a problem because nebulas
all consequences nebula just crazy is a
16 year old girl ring that hook up with
already started we're down okay they're
going to destroy Robert now put you in
the here to do this thing to your block
I just had just miss your idea not live
yes your ID uh it was a little bit more
yeah and it works make it similar to
which is it alright so let me look got
the Infinity Gauntlet everybody's
freaking out good luck all right we got
to find a way to like deal with this
yeah so the end of teaming up with
Thanos Adam warlock talking at that I'll
seems like it odors and why you never
succeed with absolute power Thanos like
why and that now more less because like
you don't really believe that you
deserve absolute power whatever anyway
they go back to the program Bueller and
it literally turns into like this dis
fight more or less and then add more
gravity of pretty big gauntlet of
nebulas what the conflict in and then
the affinity goggle story comes to an
end and then that's it boom
okay that was more or less be infinity
go ahead unless that can be made my
nephew yeah home explain to the best of
my ability and she'll take that girl was
serviced perfect
Vennela Greek yogurt yeah meander all
about this organic stofan so uh I'm
sorta do better I hope you guys enjoyed
this first episode of Rocky Top wings
all exclaiming stuff interior will have
a better name and the time to finish so
hot when you talk you're so hot when you
talk roll while you're here in silent
it's perfectly fine talking not so much
yeah those are Draganov man mod
Christmas very a mess now dragons few
when they blow fire no wonder they're
always this will make relatives again so
let us know what story you want him to
explain next if it's not tied to whom
your least show I could do but I don't
know who you closet your videos
following you on Twitter yeah without
being say guys it will bring this video
to one in well which you guys will check
out those were monster guys we're gonna
go play splatoon right now with the top
waves really so that'll be a
knowledgeable monster commands like we
did that elbow monster bumper at the
beginning in the video and I'm comic
story and yeah you know whose comic
story I do comic book videos she always
has terrible ideas like she's here oh
yeah you had all book
[Music]